if you made $1,000 a week be happy which
it does one look at the next verses that
we eat making Pig gratitude is an
unlocker I'm correct just four hundred
trillion to one I just want everybody
here this this is the reason I'm happy
24/7 365 for the rest of my life four
hundred trillion to one the odds of
becoming a human being you might not
like the human being situation you ended
up in but let me tell you this your mom
might have grabbed another glass of wine
and he never would have been hahaha I
mean four hundred trillion to one you're
more likely to win the lottery although
over a hundred million dollars nine
times in your life than being Rick and
that's why I tell you was a privilege to
be here and of course I wasn't going to
say well I'm not favorite well that's
the thing right like I'm not born in
America I'm an immigrant I'm black I'm a
girl you know all their feelings and I
hate talking about this fact as a white
man cuz I get it I get it but it doesn't
change tomorrow you leaving a comment on
Instagram easy for you to say white boy
doesn't change doesn't change it doesn't
change your [ __ ] it doesn't change your
[ __ ] and this way boys like here I'm
going to try to help you like there's
plenty of black girls I'm going to help
you there's plenty a Liam's not going to
help like I'm trying to help it's free
now how far are you from by